actually even rook takes rook would be a  draw there but you definitely don't want  to allow your players  so um just keeping his rook for now not  getting  distracted away from the white pawn  and yeah i think we'll see a draw within  the next  minute or so okay here he comes next  20 seconds or so exactly and now the  pawn will start advancing and just  look the white king is just helpless too  exactly you know the action is happening  on the right and  uh the right work cannot fand off both  the king and the pawn  so there you go okay where is the king  why what is that reaction about i think  he's unhappy i think he knew he had a  big advantage  wow and uh or maybe he's just shattered  after such an  exhausting game but it's an important  point  it's an important uh if he had won he  would  have been on six and a half points and  suddenly  he might be an eighth place